[Music]
you play the vice president yeah on your
show uh uh you recently uh met with vice
president i'm sure you've met him before
but you got to spend quite quite a bit
of time with him oh my god it was so
much fun he's such an a wonderful man
he's so uh affable and and charming and
uh it was incredible we had lunch
together
and he was he was
trying to be funny and and when in fact
when we we sort of first i first walked
into his office and he goes hey you know
he said hello hello and then he says hey
does your husband like to sleep with the
vice president because i'm trying to
convince jill it's a good idea
that's pretty that's pretty racy it's
racy but it was i mean he didn't he
didn't mean it no racism sure i
understand yeah and um and then at one
point i he i got a ride in his motorcade
because he had to anyway it's a long
story but i was in the motorcade with
him and so i had my phone
lights and it was unbelievable it was
the most
exhilarating experience of my life i
couldn't believe what's happening now uh
because here's a question on on veep you
as the vice president you have a bit of
a potty mouth on the show yeah yeah yeah
uh i is
does biden as the real vice president
does do does he ever no language ever
fly with no no he's very um
he's he's as
he i don't get the impression at all
that he's a swear he's kind of an you
know elegant guy he's very uh no he
wouldn't however plenty of people do of
course in politics i mean nixon was a
huge swear she listened to the nixon
tapes every third word right is a swear
right it's a swear
and um and i did i say it wrong i don't
know it is a swear it just sounded like
it sounded like yeah i'm pretty square
myself
he said i swear
and um uh lyndon johnson was a huge
swear in fact lyndon johnson was really
apparently he did the most extraordinary
things like he used to to intimidate
people he would go and he would sit on
the toilet and go to the bathroom while
talking to them yeah and he'd get his
way yeah somehow but i mean he would be
well there's stories about him uh he had
a very earthy sense of humor yeah
i guess you could call it that but he
was a big swear a lot of these guys are
i do that when i'm when i have a
negotiation when i'm talking to andy and
i really want to like let him know who's
boss i call him into my bathroom right
he's got a very shy bladder so i end up
winning
[Laughter]